it is great to be joined today by Anand
geared our das who's an author columnist
and on-air political analyst his latest
book as winners take all the elite
charade of changing the world it's so
great to talk to you about this because
it's something I've been thinking about
and talking about on my program for
years which is I like to use the concept
of safe change when I talk about some of
the pseudo activism that we hear from
some of the tech giants and some of the
sort of startup billionaires and huge
corporations that talk about activism
and change and improving the world and
the way I sort of summarized it and I'm
curious to hear whether whether you sort
of agree with this or would maybe tweak
it a little is the idea that those who
are in a position to really influence
significant change in the world are
going to advocate types of change that
won't endanger the status quo that
allowed them to achieve the status
they've achieved am i sort of on track
here yeah I think you know the message
that you go out to all the young people
watching this is safe sex is good safe
change is bad you know I actually call
it fake change but we're sort of getting
at the same concept and and the idea of
fake change that's at the heart of
winner-take-all is this notion that in
recent decades the rich and powerful in
the United States have shown a great
interest in social change in making the
world a better place that's visible in
Silicon Valley where it's hard to find
one of these big tech companies that
doesn't claim a world changing
civilization bounding mission none of
them just say they're here to sell ads
and make money or sell books and make
money it's you know you go to Wall
Street and virtually every bank as a CSR
project and and you know environmental
social project and they're trying to
help empower women and they're trying to
help you know homeowners recover from
the financial crisis that they caused
and you go to the mall and it's hard to
avoid products that are give one get one
you know in use bono to save the world
somehow by buying an iPhone case and
what is remarkable is that this period
that is so awash in these forms of elite
change has also been a period that is
basically punishing for the working and
middle classes in this country and so
you have a situation where the rich and
powerful are talking a lot about doing
well by doing good giving back making a
difference but they are building and
operating and maintaining a system that
keeps them on top locks most people out
and so the kind of change that they
peddle is fake change in my view it's
change that does not change their own
position it's changed it does not change
the social arrangements that allow them
to win and and keep others out it's the
kind of change that allows you know
their own world to not change at all and
the kind of generosity that allows
injustice to fester we've been talking a
lot on my show and I think some in my
audience disagree with my position on
the sort of use of techniques like the
heckling of politicians in public we can
debate whether we think that's useful or
not or whatever whatever activism
technique we want to talk about and one
of the points I've been making is that
if you stick to doing activism and
lobbying for change only in the ways
that those in power are comfortable with
you're immediately conceding that the
scope of the change you can achieve is
much smaller than what it is that that
may actually need to happen or that you
may be targeting and for me it's a sort
of similar thing with corporations and
that when you hear an announcement about
major giving campaigns that some huge
multinational is going to be doing we
focus on well what exactly will that
money do and it becomes almost
background that it will maintain the
exact infrastructure that allowed that
corporation to consolidate assets and
power in this way and I'm curious to
hear from you what are ways to get
around this system because those who are
telling us what types of activism are
okay
are the ones who benefit from that
narrow scope one thing I would say I
think first of all you're absolutely
right that you know I think we live in
actually a very tame and safe age in
which there has been you know there have
been some amazing protest movements but
in general I think a lot of people have
stayed away from protest as a way of
making things different I had many of my
book tour events over the last couple
months people women in their 70s and 80s
have come up to me and kind of whisper
what is up with your generation like
when we saw problems we shut down
streets we shut down universities we
shut down how how is it did nothing's
getting shut down you know with with
some occasional exceptions during the
rise of you know a strongman demagogue
fueled by white nationalism in the
United States well you could argue that
you know Trump has has led to you know
much much less civil disobedience then
you would expect given the belief that
many people have I think justified that
this is an existential crisis for the
Republic
you know I think one of the things that
does remain very powerful in terms of
this plutocratic Lyon society is that it
is upheld not by tanks so much as by
ideas and that's actually an optimistic
message you know I wrote this book
because I thought that there were
actually some very flimsy fraudulent but
widely believed ideas a kind of
tyrannical reign of sweet-smelling
[ __ ] that upheld this kind of rule
by billionaires and I actually really
believe that if people stopped believing
billionaire [ __ ]
a lot of new political political
possibilities come into play you know
today for example we have the
announcement of Amazon opening its
second headquarters yes York and
Northern Virginia well first of all
there's no such thing as a second
headquarters any more than there's no
such thing as a second head second of
all if your second
quarters is two different places that's
not really a second headquarters that's
just to a new office so we all got
played and a bunch of places got you
know coaxed into offering tax breaks for
nothing and what I would say that's
interesting is having written about this
for a couple years I would say the
public reaction today when I tweet about
this issue today there is an awareness
today to see through this kind of thing
that there wasn't a few years ago people
are starting to realize that we've lived
in this age in which companies rule us
and and even our government just lives
in the world that companies create and
I'm gratified when I see the reaction of
the Amazon story I think people are
immediately going to like what are the
tax breaks what did we sign away that
the kind of gratitude reflex has has
actually gone away you know and it was
the same thing when Jeff Bezos of Amazon
announced his two billion-dollar
philanthropic gift you know the the tone
and tenor with which we kind of treat
and understand these these plutocrats
has changed people were immediately
asking well do you pay people enough
what's your taxable in situation like
them and so I believe that the first
step to kind of protesting the
plutocratic rule in America is telling
the truth and ask little hard questions
and I think this is a very important
role for the media to play in terms of
what is the default story when you have
an announcement like this that's
actually what I wanted to get to next
which is is there a degree to or to what
degree does corporate media protect the
fake change narrative by only giving
minor attention to the more serious
ideas of change even when those ideas
are pretty popular among people like do
you think the government has a basic
duty to provide some level of health
care whether or not you can pay for it
that is very popular in the United
States when asked fairly but the
narrative around Medicare for all is of
this extremist idea that barely deserves
attention look I I I'm not sure it's
always because I mean the corporate
media includes many different things you
know I think there there there is some
media that because it is corporate is
certain ideas but I think the problem
when you look at the really great papers
and magazines the problem is not their
corporate ownership I think it's
actually something having worked at the
New York Times for many years having you
know known a lot of people within that
media there is a kind of real wariness
and skepticism of political power and a
lot of the self-image of journalists was
shaped by Watergate in this country and
the idea that people with political
power need to be held to account
investigated etc and of course those
publications also investigate the
private sector and business but I think
often with these kind of entrepreneur
hero figures the coverage has just been
a little puffier you know I think if you
think about something like Goldman Sachs
or you know you know Facebook and
Cambridge analytic ah like you end up
getting very serious scrutiny but on the
way up a company like uber or Facebook
while it's still growing has a little
bit more of a free ride even though it's
exerting an enormous amount of power and
you know when you have these people
Steve Case is starting an impact fund
and that's not often it goes straight to
here is how this person is trying to
make things better instead of why do
they have that much money what is what
tax measures of these other tax measures
that they are using or are those
creating harm to this society on a scale
that Dwarfs the good that they're doing
in other words writing about rich people
the way we write about senators and
congressmen which is always with a
gimlet eye always trying to understand
what's behind and I you know I do think
there's a way in which we've turned the
entrepreneur king of our age into these
kind of swashbuckling heroes that has
created space for them to to rule us
instead of just being part of the mix on
that note I mean it in what way does
this relate to the rise of Trump the
concept of fake
the coverage of these corporate sort of
pseudo heroes as they are perceived by
some and what's the relationship there I
think an uncomfortable truth is that the
plutocratic kind of philanthropy a
fabulous class pave the way for Donald
Trump in two important ways the first
way they did so is by aggressively
peddling non solutions to grave problems
for 30 or 40 years as social mobility
was vanishing from the United States as
the education system was failing to
prepare people for a new world of
technology and automation and and
globalization as you had the shift from
a industrial economy to a service
economy etc etc etc we just didn't do
any of the really big things we needed
to do to prepare people for the new
world and meanwhile we told women to
lean in we both the Charter School here
and there we did the kind of you know we
put billionaires names on public
libraries while not actually funding
public libraries more we did all the
kind of pseudo changes that that created
the kind of the illusion of change
without without the reality so those
philanthropists created space for Donald
Trump by not solving things that he
could then point to and say like
America's not Great America can be made
great again now of course what he meant
by that was also enormous ly tinged by
outright racism but the racism and
economics work together in the sense
that this country is rigged it does not
work for people anymore is something
that actually unites people on the left
and right people of color white people
women and men and he tapped into both
the racial undercurrents and that sense
of things being rigged in a way that was
incredibly powerful the second way those
people paved the way for him is they
gave him his playbook and when Donald
Trump says you know the people who kind
of traded with Mexico and China
themselves in their own business are the
people best able to get us a trade deal
that is
philanthropist idea of the arsonists
being the best firefighters of the
McKenzie and Goldman Sachs trained
people being the best foundation
executives and poverty Warriors when
Donald Trump says you know I alone can
fix it that is that idea of the
businessman being specially capable of
solving our problems when Donald Trump
seeks to enrich himself possibly in
violation of the Immanuel emoluments
cause the Constitution while fighting
for the least among us that again is
this notion of the win-win that you see
in the financier capitalist which is I
should be able to profit from helping
others and so Donald Trump is in many
ways what you get when you task
billionaires with changing the world
Donald Trump is what you get when you
have a culture that believes in
billionaire saviors and I think it's
very notable that if you look at a lot
of the people the left has fantasized
about during the Trump era among that
set of names is Mark Zuckerberg Howard
Schultz Michael Bloomberg Tom Styer and
Oprah now I like Oprah but I gotta say
that list suggests me a fundamental
misunderstanding of our age because if
your conclusion from the Trump era is
that we need better billionaires sugar
daddies and sugar much I don't think
you're I don't think you understand the
moment we are in we need to actually
look at within this is not just about
Trump we look within what is it in us
that has conflated wealth with virtue
and intelligence and that looks to be
saved by rich people when a rich person
who's not even as rigid he claims is
defrauding our republic and and even
today we spoke about on the program are
speaking about on the program Fox News
ridiculing Alexandria Castillo Cortez
because she's not rich as if obviously
we should have elected officials who are
wealthy and it's it's all part of this
dynamic that you described in the book
which is excellent winners take all the
elite charade of changing the world
we've been speaking with the book's
author Anand Giridhar das author
columnist on air political analyst
a pleasure speaking to you today thank
you so much for having me